et wang hao sur l'actualité politique
sur l'actualité économique sur
l'actualité sociale sur l'international
le titre alors tant pis je dis la vérité
ça veut dire que bon ceux qui sont pas
content mais c'est leur problème mais je
dis la vérité parce que je considère
qu'il y a cosmo d'ossun catégorie de
vérité qui sont cachés c'est à lire
alors premièrement il ya des vérités
dont on ne parle pas parce qu'on a un
peu honte
il ya des vérités dont on ne parle pas à
trop parce qu on n'a pas le courage
politique de les exprimer
il ya des vérités dont on parle guère
qui sont cachés parce que on n'a pas le
courage de faire son autocritique
il ya des vérités qui sont cachés par ce
que il y à ce que j'appelle la dictature
de l'idéologie et du politiquement
correct dictature intellectuelle
et puis il ya aussi des vérités qui sont
cachés parce que le citoyen et puis un
certain nombre d'organes de presse se
bouche les oreilles et se bouche les
yeux de raymond occolier dit un certain
nombre de choses mais apporte des
solutions
oui par exemple quand je parle des
sujets qui défraie la chronique
les retraités les personnes âgées
souhaitent que en augmentent leur
passion alors évidemment la france est
dans une situation financière
épouvantable combien de citoyens savent
que chaque seconde chaque seconde qui
passe la dette de la france augmentent
de 2600 65 euros mais dans le même temps
il y a des dépôts ce que l'on n'aurait
pu éviter par exemple on est passé
aujourd'hui dans le budget de l'état
il y à au moins 36 milliards d'euros qui
sont consacrés à la dissuasion nucléaire
un homme prestigieux michel rocard
expliqué que si on diminue est quelque
peu la dissuasion nucléaire la
construction de bombes atomiques pour
faire simple et bien on pourrait
récupérer plusieurs milliards pour
augmenter les patients pour soulager les
hôpitaux qui en a bien besoin
et puis aussi pour aider les petites
communes vous donner une vision globale
du développement
en disant qu'il faut faire beaucoup de
choses qu'il faut aider la jeunesse
qu'il faut affronter les défis majeurs
pour qu'il faut être ensemble autour de
la table de la fraternité oui je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous devons être de bons
élèves de nelson mandela parce qu'il ya
des gens qui qui prétendent défendre les
idées de mandela il se réclame de
mandela mais ils sont très loin mandela
il dit il faut leur est devenu de panser
les blessures
nelson mandela dit que si tu veux faire
la paix avec ton ennemi travail avec ton
ami et on any deviendra son associé
aujourd'hui nous devons rassembler tout
l'arc en ciel de la société
martiniquaise lénaig les mulets bekele
si oui les arabes les indiens tout l'arc
en ciel et travailler ensemble
fraternellement
parce que si nous ne travaillons pas
ensemble fraternellement
nous risquons de disparaître tous comme
des imbéciles ça d'ailleurs commencé un
petit peu parce que chaque année il y à
3500 habitants qui fuient la martinique
où chercher la vie ailleurs c'est comme
si la commune de basket ou des anses
d'arlet était vrillé de la carte chaque
année vraiment con lyon on a
l'impression que vous n'avez pas terminé
avec son premier livre où vous dites un
certain nombre de vérités
vous préparez déjà notre tom de ça va
dépendre de l'accueil des lecteurs
s'il ya un accueil suffisant de lecteurs
je suis en train de réunir effectivement
les ingrédients prescrit un tome 2